.
>>> THE DEBATE OVER WHETHER
VACCINE MANDATES SHOULD APPLY TO
AIR TRAVEL IS ONLY INTENSIFYING
AS CASES CONTINUE TO SOAR.
MY NEXT GUEST SAW THIS COMING
MONTHS AGO AND WROTE ABOUT IT IN
"THE WASHINGTON POST."
HERE WAS HIS TAKE.
BIDEN'S VACCINE MANDATES ARE NOT
ENOUGH.
HE MUST ALSO MANDATE VACCINES
FOR TRAVEL.
DR. ZEKE EMMANUEL, FORMER MEMBER
OF THEN-PRESIDENT BIDEN'S COVID
ADVISORY BOARD JOINS ME NOW.
BEFORE WE GET TO THE AIRLINE
SITUATION, I GIVE CREDIT TO DR.
FAUCI FOR COMING ON AND TALKING
ABOUT THE CONFUSING NATURE OF
THIS RECENT CDC GUIDANCE.
I DON'T KNOW THAT WE SHED ANY
NEW LIGHT ON THE SITUATION, BUT
REACT.
>> IF YOU WILL, TO THOSE ISSUES
BEFORE WE TALK ABOUT AIRLINE
TRAVEL.
>> WELL, I AM ACTUALLY -- I HAVE
BEEN VERY NOT SO MUCH CONFUSED
BUT PERPLEXED BY WHY THE CDC DID
THAT.
IT DOESN'T SEEM TO BE MEDICALLY
INDICATED, THE FACT THAT PEOPLE
DON'T -- SHOULDN'T TEST AFTER
FIVE DAYS BEFORE THEY TAKE
THEMSELVES OUT OF ISOLATION
SEEMS VERY PERPLEXING NOW.
MAYBE THEY SHOULDN'T GET A RAPID
TEST, BUT A PCR, BUT WE DON'T
HAVE AVAILABILITY OF PCR.
THAT CERTAINLY HAS TO BE A
COMPONENT OF IT.
THIS ISSUE OF WEARING A MASK
WHERE THE CDC DID NOT SPECIFY
HIGH-QUALITY MASKS LIKE N95s, I
THINK THAT WAS ALSO PROBLEMATIC.
AND IF YOU ARE REALLY ASKING
PEOPLE WHO ARE, YOU KNOW, ARE
YOU SYMPTOMATIC, ASYMPTOMATIC,
THIS ISN'T EXACTLY VERY CLEARLY
SPECIFIED FOR PEOPLE.
THERE IS A LOT OF JUDGMENT BY
PEOPLE AS TO WHAT QUALIFIES.
AND SO I THINK ON THE WHOLE
IT'S -- IT ACTUALLY ISN'T
HELPING, AND THERE IS, I THINK,
FOR MANY OF US, A GREAT DEAL OF
SUSPICION THAT, AS YOU PUT IT, I
THINK, IT WAS ECONOMIC REASONS.
IT'S NOT THE HEALTH OF PEOPLE.
IT'S THE OTHER CONSIDERATIONS.
CAN WE KEEP THE HOSPITALS
FUNCTIONING, CAN WE KEEP THE
AIRLINES FUNCTIONING AND THINGS
LIKE THAT THAT REALLY WEIGHED
HEAVILY IN THIS DETERMINATION.
BACK IN SEPTEMBER IN "THE
WASHINGTON POST," AS I POINTED
OUT, YOU ADVOCATED FOR THERE TO
ABTRAVEL MANDATE.
ARE YOU SURPRISED THAT STEP HAS
NOT BEEN TAKEN AND DID DR. FAUCI
IN RESPONDING TO THAT ISSUE SAY
ANYTHING THAT CAUGHT YOUR EAR?
>> I AM SURPRISED.
I THINK IT'S A MISTAKE.
WE, OBVIOUSLY, THOUGHT MANY
MONTHS AGO THAT WE SHOULD PUT IT
IN PLACE.
WE ARGUED FOR IT IN SEPTEMBER
BECAUSE WE ANTICIPATED THAT
PEOPLE WOULD NEED TWO VACCINES
AND IF YOU WANTED TO PREVENT
TRANSMISSION DURING
THANKSGIVING, THAT WAS GOING TO
BE AN IMPORTANT ELEMENT.
ESPECIALLY BECAUSE IT'S NOT JUST
ON THE AIRPLANES.
IT'S IN THE AIRPORTS.
IT'S IN THE TRANSPORTATION TO
AND FROM THE AIRPORTS THAT YOU
HAVE POTENTIAL FOR TRANSMISSION.
IT SUGGESTS TO ME THAT TONY
FAUCI IS INTERESTED IN HAVING
THE MANDATE.
I THINK THAT'S WHAT HIS ORIGINAL
COMMENT SUGGESTED, BUT THAT
THERE ARE OTHER PEOPLE IN THE
WHITE HOUSE ABOVE HIM, I GUESS,
WHO ARE NOT INTERESTED AND NOT
SUPPORTIVE OF THAT.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT THE
CALCULATION IS AND I DON'T KNOW
WHY WE WANT IT ON INTERNATIONAL
TRAVEL BUT NOT DOMESTIC TRAVEL.
THAT DOESN'T MAKE SENSE TO ME.
THERE IS A LOGISTICAL ISSUE OF
HOW PEOPLE PROVE THEY ARE
VACCINATED, THE FACT THAT WE
HAVE NOT PUT IN A GOOD VACCINE
CERTIFICATION SYSTEM.
SO THAT IS PART OF IT, I'M SURE.
>> I SHOULD POINT OUT THAT YOU
EXTEND THAT TO INTERSTATE
TRAVEL, INCLUDING BUSES AND
RAILWAYS AS WELL, NOT JUST
AIRLINE TLAFL.
>> YEAH.
IF YOU GO ON TO TRAINS AND YOU
TAKE AN AMTRAK TRAIN, YOU CAN
SEE THAT, YOU KNOW, THERE IS
CHANCES FOR PLENTY -- MINE,
THOSE ARE BIG CARS, PEOPLE ARE
IN THEM.
EVEN IF THE AIR IS CIRCULATED,
MULTIPLE TIMES IN AN HOUR,
PEOPLE AREN'T, I WOULD SAY,
ASSIDUOUS IN THEIR MASK-WEARING.
THEY ARE EATING ON THE TRAINS.
THAT IS ANOTHER PLACE WHERE WE
COULD V TRANSMISSION, ESPECIALLY
WITH SOMETHING HIGHLY
CONTAGIOUS.
>> DO YOU THINK IT'S OUT OF
CONCERN FOR PRIVATE INDUSTRY?
I MEAN, IN VIEW OF DR. FAUCI'S
COMMENT, ECONOMIC WAS NOT A WORD
HE USED TO, I USED THAT.
BUT IN VIEW OF WHAT HE DID SAY,
DO YOU THINK THERE IS CONCERN
THAT THE AIRLINE INDUSTRY HAS
ALREADY BEEN RATTLED AND THAT
PROBABLY THEY WOULD SUFFER IF,
IN FACT, A MANDATE WERE TO BE
PUT IN PLACE?
>> I DON'T ACTUALLY THINK THEY
WOULD SUFFER.
AGAIN, I THINK IT'S POSSIBLE
THAT A LOT OF PEOPLE WOULD FEEL
SAFER.
I THINK WHAT PEOPLE ARE
SUFFERING FROM IS THE FACT THAT
THERE IS A VERY HIGHLY
TRANSMISSABLE VARIANT OUT THERE
AND YOU SEE PEOPLE PULLING BACK,
CANCELING AIRPLANE TRIPS,
CANCELING HOTEL RESERVATIONS,
NOT GOING TO THE THEATER, ET
CETERA.
IF PEOPLE WERE MORE CONFIDENT
THAT TRANSMISSION WAS LOW, YOU
WOULD PROBABLY SEE A LOT MORE OF
THAT.
AND THE WAY TO GET THAT KIND OF
COMMUNITY LEVEL TRANSMISSION TO
BE LOW IS TO HAVE MORE PEOPLE
VACCINATED.
THE REASON TO DO THE VACCINES
FOR TRAVEL IS TO GET MORE PEOPLE
VACCINATED.
THAT IS THE FUNDAMENTAL POINT.
>> DR. EMMANUEL, FROM SOCIAL
MEDIA, PUT IT UP ON THE SCREEN.
I WILL READ IT ALOUD SO WE CAN
RESPOND.
WHAT DO WE HAVE?
WE DON'T HAVE A CHOICE WHO WE
ARE STUFFED INTO A CABIN WITH,
SAYS JULIE.
YOU, OBVIOUSLY, AGREE WITH THAT
POINT?
>> YES.
I AGREE WITH THAT POINT.
AND I THINK THE SAME THING IS
TRUE WHEN YOU GO TO A
RESTAURANT, WHEN YOU GO TO THE
THEATER, WHEN YOU GO OUTDOORS --
WHEN YOU GO INTO SOME FACILITY.
YOU DON'T CHOOSE WHO THEY ARE.
YOU DON'T KNOW HOW GOOD THE
VENTILATION IS.
ALTHOUGH ON AIRPLANES IT IS
GOOD.
YOU KNOW, A LOT OF PEOPLE ARE
NOT GOOD ABOUT WEARING
HIGH-QUALITY MASKS AND KEEPING
THEM OVER THEIR NOSE AND WELL
SEALED.
>> LOOK, IT CAN BE DONE.
I HAVE NOTED BEFORE THE FIRST
TIME -- THIS WILL SOUND ODD.
THE FIRST TIME I WAS ASKED TO
SHOW PROOF OF VACCINATION WAS AT
A CONCERT I WENT TO.
WAS IT THE MOST ARDUOUS OF
INSPECTIONS?
NOT REALLY.
I APPRECIATED IT AND 40,000
PEOPLE WERE THERE THAT MIGHT.
ONE MORE.
PUT IT BACK ON THE SCREEN.
IDEALLY, YES, BUT PERCEIVED LOSS
OF LIBERTIES.
THAT'S A GOOD ARGUMENT.
WHAT DO YOU SAY WHO SAY THOSE
TREAD ON ME?
AN INTRUSION ON MY PERSONAL
LIBERTIES?
>> LOOK, YOU I THINK I SAID IT
BEFORE.
THIS IS NOT AN ARGUMENT THAT ANY
AMERICAN FOUNDING FATHER WOULD
UNDERSTAND.
THEY WOULD BE CONFUSED.
YOU MEAN YOU ARE GOING TO GO
AROUND WITH SOMETHING
CONTAGIOUS, SOMETHING THAT COULD
KILL OTHER PEOPLE, AND YOU SAY
THAT YOU HAVE THE LIBERTY TO DO
THAT?
THEY WOULDN'T RECOGNIZE THAT.
IT'S NOT A MATTER OF LIBERTY.
LIBERTY IS WHEN YOU DON'T
IMPINGE AND THREATEN THE WELL
BEING OF YOUR NEIGHBOR.
WHEN YOU THREATEN THE WELL BEING
OF YOUR NEIGHBOR BECAUSE YOU ARE
NOT VACCINATED, YOU HAVE --
AREN'T TAKING PRECAUTIONS THAT'S
NOT LIBERTY.
THAT'S NOT TAKING INDIVIDUAL
RESPONSIBILITY.
AND I THINK THAT IS THE
FUNDAMENTAL ISSUE.
WHEN YOU HAVE AN INFECTIOUS
DISEASE CIRCULATING BE AND YOU
COULD BE SPREADING IT, YOU ARE
NOT AT LIBERTY TO INFECT OTHER
PEOPLE AND POTENTIALLY END THE